nazim zahawi is standing by for us uh
this morning hello to minister thanks
for joining us on the programme
today uh before we move on to other
topics let's talk uh about the u.s
election if we may have thought for the
democratic
process and a president who appears not
to want to accept it
well it's clearly a big election uh
it's a great endorsement of democracies
the highest turnout since i think
1900 but it's a very close election and
i think uh we have to
wait to see the results uh as you have
just reported uh it is very close
uh election uh and then of course
um we will congratulate uh whoever
is the occupant of the white house um
the relationship between
london and washington will always remain
very close and very special so you're
very happy with the way the president's
conducting himself at the moment
well i think it's good practice okay for
a british minister and the british
government not to comment
on uh the elections of
a great democracy like the united states
and i think
the important thing is for us to wait
for the outcome of
this closely contested election
and i think it's only wise i hope you
agree that the british government
congratulates the
the winner when that outcome is clear no
i don't agree
um i want to put it to you that uh
twitter is censoring
the president of the united states of
the mayor of america for misleading
content
uh he is um asking his supporters to
demonstrate
in areas of the united states where he
feels that the election is being stolen
from him
without any evidence whatsoever and he
makes these comments
from the white house you feel that
that's acceptable
well as i said i think it's unwise for a
british minister or british government
to
comment on a live election
that is closely contested in a great
democracy like the united states
the one thing i would say is of course
the united states has very robust
institutions
um and have always even the most
difficult uh closely contested elections
like the 2000 election
have actually reached a a an outcome
that
works and actually delivers a message to
the world that democracy works
uh yeah i'm not really asking you about
the election or commenting on the
election i'm asking you to comment
on the behavior of the president
well you will you will again forgive me
i will not comment on
a a live election between
two excellent candidates in a very
closely fought contest
that at the moment the outcome is
unclear and until we have all the facts
before us
it will be unwise for a british minister
to comment
on the great democratic process of the
united states of america
okay let's talk about the furlough
scheme at home should we um
and the latest that we've been hearing
from the chancellor overnight
um it's been extended until march this
fuller scheme i mean it is a full-blown
tyre screeching u-turn isn't it
well look um the important thing is to
always
remain close to what is happening in the
economy i'm the business and
industry minister and uh the british
chambers of commerce who are speaking to
two days ago were quite rightly
reminding me that businesses wanted
certainty and therefore wanted much more
clarity
on furlough and it's exactly what
rishi's done he's responded to that
and i think rishi's to be commended
for basically being able to flex
the interventions we're making as this
virus
is being fought in each and every part
of the country
and of course as we see what is
happening to the economy and get
feedback from businesses so
you know whether you want to call it a
a u-turn i i disagree with you i think
actually it is
demonstrating a government and a
chancellor that is responsive
to the needs of business and they but
the british chambers of commerce were
very clear they wanted
a much clearer uh longer term uh
intervention in the furlough scheme and
it's exactly what the chancellor's
delivered
extending it to the end of march um
why didn't it happen when northern
leaders wanted it
well when we were in negotiations with
steve rotherman liverpool and i paid
tribute to him
and he very quickly went into tier three
and actually
we've seen the numbers come down in
cases by about 50 percent
there and with other northern leaders we
were taking the regional
approach to uh dealing with the virus
now that we have decided that we needed
a further
intervention of this additional four
weeks of lockdown to really bear down
on the virus uh then uh the chancellor
quite rightly consulted
and did the right thing to extend follow
by the way furlough is available
to wales and to other regions
up until the end of october anyway
yeah um you are spending billions
keeping people in jobs
that won't exist come march
what happened to the comments made by
you and many of your colleagues um
during the process of the last few weeks
when you've been on my program saying
that you're focusing on viable jobs
well first of all um you know when the
situation changed
and we have clearly had to go further in
our interventions because the virus was
beginning to spike you heard
simon stevens yesterday talk about
hospitalization
going up from 2600 to over 12
000 people in hospital and in some areas
the ventilator beds are beginning
to come under pressure then you have to
respond accordingly and because of this
further intervention the further
uh four weeks of uh uh lockdown
uh in england then it's only right that
we
make sure that businesses that are being
asked to close
um that their you know their sales order
book has gone to zero
uh should get that additional help to
try and make sure they can
uh survive this difficult uh period and
then come out of the other end
uh to be able to plan forward now the
reason for the extension
until the end of march is because we
know that order books don't come back
very the next day they don't come back
on the on the third of december
and everything goes back to normal
there's a lag time which is why i think
it's the
right thing to do to give businesses
that additional
um cushion if i can describe it as that
as that
to be able to recover from covert and
i'm certain that we will recover
uh from covid i talked to about 60
percent of the economy the sectors that
i
i cover and yes it's a tough time but
actually many of them
see that the government's interventions
are the right ones at the right time
the imf k yesterday the head of the imf
said this is the most coordinated
intervention she's seeing anywhere in
the world and commends it to other
world leaders as well yeah i bet they're
not um commending your tnt
um track and trace systems though are
they i mean we've even heard from the
prime minister saying
that he apologized for the test and
trace system it really needs to be
better
if we are going to come out of this
lockdown on the 2nd
of december what can you do to convince
my viewers this morning that that is
what's going to happen week ending 28th
of october 40
of people who have been in contact with
someone testing positive
the virus have not been contacted
you're right to say that it needs to
improve and uh improvements are being
made rapidly so
the turnaround time is one of the uh big
issues so the speed at which
you can turn around tests uh has gone up
uh
from about 40 turnaround time of tests
within 24 hours
to 60 this week that's good because
we're seeing greater capacity
in testing now we're over that 500 000
capacity that
you and i have talked about on a number
of interviews on your show
1.7 million people have been contacted
in are isolating because of
the test and trace system but you're
right we need to get
better over a hundred uh local teams are
now
um being supported to do more local
tests and trades we know
that works incredibly well to you know
for those difficult
to to get to cases and so we will be
making improvements all the time
to the system liverpool is uh as of
today with the support of two thousand
uh of our uh soldiers uh we'll be going
into a mass testing program which i
think again
will continue uh the effort to get ahead
of the virus especially
on testing and and of course on tracing
as well
you're also getting a kicking for these
official statistics that you uh
tend to show us at downing street and
the official statistics watchdog
has issued a warning to the government
for using coronavirus data
in ways which can confuse the public
that's not on is it why are you doing
that
well first of all we listen very
carefully to the uh official
statistics watchdog and make sure that
we respond accordingly
and some people were you know critical
around some of the models
and they are models the important thing
to remember okay
is uh the clarity with which simon
stevens the head of nhs england
demonstrated not modeling not forecast
but
real numbers of people in hospitals
with covid going up from 2 600 a month
ago to
over 12 000 this month that is
irrefutable so that the
the difficulty we've had which is why
we've had to take this really hard
decision
you know it doesn't sit easy with the
business and industry minister to have
to ask businesses
to close their their doors uh to trade
um is because we were seeing that in
some parts of the country
the nhs uh was beginning to
reach a stage where they would have to
make really awful choices
uh morally awful terms of who to put on
a ventilator
if they run out of ventilated capacity
which is why we've had to make
these interventions so i take on board
what the
official statistics watchdog says
and we will always strive to improve our
graphs and our presentations
but at the same time the facts are very
clear that we've had to make this very
difficult decision
i'm certain that that actually this
decision is the right one but also will
ultimately deliver that what we all want
to see which is that reduction
in the r number and then we can go back
to the tier system
um that we were very much focused on
before this this
national intervention except it's not
very clear at all is it that's the whole
point
of the official statistics watchdog
saying it's not clear
it's not done in a timely manner and
they are statistics that are just not
clear you're asking people
to put their lives on hold for a month
and you're confusing us
with stats and graphs we don't
understand and many that are out of date
well we will strive to improve them i'd
absolutely take that on board
but i would just go back and remind your
viewers that putting aside all the
models
we know that in a in a period of four
weeks
um the number of people in hospital rose
by
ten thousand um that is a a an
unsustainable level of increase of the
number of people
going into hospital and of course the
death penalty gave us stats
we're talking about 4 000 deaths a day
and and you know that that stat
has not been proven to be true well as i
said that that is that was a model
um that was never and as the uh chief
medical officer chris whittie said you
know that that
that is one model and there were several
models and it was only right that we
publish as much as possible so people
can see
and and other statisticians can look at
which is why we're having this debate
is because people are looking at the
modeling
very very carefully but actually putting
aside
all the modelling the real numbers of
real people
in hospital suffering with covid uh a
number of them
uh hundreds of them now dying you know
from about 50 deaths um
a day we're now on an average about 300
deaths a day that is
far too high and actually the right
thing to do
is to make this intervention i am
certain the british people
understand that and actually their
behavior overall
has been incredibly uh positive to see
people
in liverpool and in nottingham the case
rates have already come down by 50
in liverpool 60 in nottingham since they
introduced the tier 3 measures
so people are behaving in a really
positive way
to make sure that we get this virus
under control so that we can come out of
these
interventions on the second of december
mr minister always a pleasure thanks
very much indeed for joining us this
morning